hi and welcome to vwr your search is
over whether you're a university
researcher an industrial medicinal
chemist or an independent innovator
pursuing your dream at a startup vwr is
proud to bring you all you need for
organic synthesis from state-of-the-art
fume hoods to specialty glassware to
building blocks catalyst and dry
solvents to flash prep and thin layer
chromatography products as well as
relevant equipment and instruments and
lab supplies you will find unparalleled
product choice at vwr in addition vwr
offers a complete range of safety
personal protection & waste disposal
products as well as technical validation
and e-business services that can help
you further optimize your logistics and
purchasing functions product choice
differentiated services and operational
excellence is what makes VW are the one
supplier that delivers exactly what you
need so you can focus on your work one
powerful tool designed to reduce the
time and complexity involved in finding
and ordering organic compounds is the VW
our building blocks portal powered by ii
molecules pwrs product and service
solutions plus ii molecules data and
chemical sourcing expertise combined to
deliver a streamlined search source an
order process for chemical building
blocks so you can focus on your
discovery and that's just one of the
many novel solutions that vwr has
created specifically for organic
synthesis explorer them all on VW are
calm you are calm hello everyone thank
you for joining us for CN second annual
virtual symposium advances and drug
discovery and development on Mitch
Garcia an assistant editor at cen and
Viva delighted to introduce our next
speaker who is Christopher Austin from
the net
no centre of advancing translational
sciences Chris release presenting a talk
entitled catalyzing translational
innovation I'll be back to moderate a
Q&A session immediately following the
presentation and we welcome your
questions at any time just click the
green Q&A button in the left corner of
your screen if you need any technical
assistance during the presentation
please click on the support button
located top right of your screen please
note that CN does not endorse any
company products or services that may be
mentioned in this presentation and
finally this talk will be archived and
available on demand at the conference
website for three months after the live
broadcast until December 16 2015 and now
I'm delighted to hand over to Chris all
right well thank you for to everybody
for joining us I'm Chris Austin I'm the
director of the National Center for
advancing translational sciences and I'm
going to run through with you in the
next half an hour or so what n cats is
doing in the areas of not only chemical
sciences but drug discovery and
development and I decided to make this
purposely broad rather than talking to
our chemist colleagues only I decided to
talk to the whole community so I'm going
to include some of the clinical work
that we do as well so you'll have a full
sense of what mcats does so let's just
jump in sometimes I'm asked why in cats
and cats was started as the newest
component of the NIH about four years
ago a little bit less than that and
among the reasons was this one that I
think we're all painfully aware of that
that is that we really live in a
paradoxical time scientifically and
medically that on the one hand we know
more about ourselves and health and
disease than we ever have perhaps
exemplified by the genome project but
there many other examples but if we ask
well have the epical changes in science
and medicine that have happened
the last 50 years been paralleled by
epical changes in health of the American
population or any population for the
most part the answer that question is a
resounding no and to some degree that's
because we really don't understand very
well how to go from what's on the left
what's on the right and there's a lot of
knock-on effects of this but among them
are that people are on healthier than
they should be in funders frankly if the
biomedical research Enterprise have
either gotten impatient or have lost
patience with us completely in terms of
our ability to deliver lease on this
part of our mission the the good part
however the good side of what's happened
in the last 30 years really since I was
in training is this which rather
remarkable graph this is looking at the
the number of disorders in the online
inheritance in man database from NLM and
CBI and and this is what the graph looks
like that is from the early to mid 80s
when the number of disorders that like a
basis of which was known was handful
going back to the original one which was
sickle hemoglobin from by Linus Pauling
in 1949 and then probably a lot of you
remember cystic fibrosis in 1989 then
Huntington's disease in 1990 1991 this
number really started to go up when
large amounts of sequence data started
getting put in the human and in the
public databases as part of the genome
project and the remarkable thing now is
30 years later there's almost 5,500
disorders of the seven thousand or so
disorders that affect the human family
the molecular basis of which is known
that's the good news the bad news is
that there are treatments for only about
500 of them now part of this is of
course due to the fact that as we all
know probably on this webinar takes
somewhere around 10 to 15 years after a
target is identified and validated
before a drug would be available but but
but the actually the pace of
of diseases becoming treatable for the
first time it's actually not changed in
the last 15 years still about three to
four a year of these diseases that go
from untreatable to treatable most new
drugs are approved for conditions that
already have a drug approved for them so
when when mcats was was formed to try to
address this problem we we had to first
define what the heck translation is this
is a sort of an unfortunate word because
it has many meanings particularly
non-scientific meetings I was a lot of
you will be amused by the fact that when
I became director of an cats I was asked
whether the National Center for
advancing translational sciences studies
linguistics because of course to any
normal person is not a scientist that's
what translation means so we spent some
time defining what we mean by
translation and it's it's really a quite
broad definition it's the whole process
by which an observation that's made by a
scientist in the lab a doc in the clinic
or a public health person in the
community makes the whole process of
turning that observation where a light
bulb goes off and says mean what's this
observation might be able to gives me an
insight that might be able to address
this this particular scientific problem
or health problem in an effective way
the whole process of creating that
intervention that drug that device of
the behavioral intervention and that's
showing that it's useful
in health meta visuals and then in the
public that whole process from idea to
public health is what we define as
translation but you notice that the
mcats is not the National Center for
translation every Center at every
institutional 27 institutes and centers
at NIH for the most part do translation
and of course many organizations outside
of NIH of course lo biopharma industry
does this and so so we're not the
National Center for advancing
translation for say where the National
Center for advancing translational
science so is translational science what
we define this it's the field of
investigation that seeks to understand
what the general principles are by which
this whole process happens and both
scientific principles and operational
principles I think all of us who work in
this field are again painfully aware
that this is it's a remarkably empirical
process mainly a remarkably trial and
error process we wouldn't understand the
science underneath underlying most steps
of the translational process and our
hypothesis is that unless we can
understand those general principles the
translation will remain an empirical
phenomenological trial and error and
mainly error process and only by
understanding the general principles
will be able to turn it into a
predictive science and therefore be more
efficient lower costs faster etc so with
that vision here's the mcats mission I
don't want to dwell on this but I just
want to emphasize a couple of words the
first is the word catalyzed this group's
knows what a catalyst is catalysts of
course is it's an entity that brings
together reactants that don't work by
themselves and allows them to produce a
product that they otherwise wouldn't by
themselves and that's really what mcats
does everything that we do is a
collaboration with someone either at NIH
or in an industry and nonprofit FDA etc
and what do we catalytic of our
generation of new ways of doing things
it's very clear that
that the biggest impact in science comes
from new methods new technologies new
ways of doing things and that's really
what what in Katz's aims to do it's
important that I mentioned this on the
catalytic part that that that everything
we do is a collaboration and there are
in fact 27 institutes and centers that
make up NIH and they all have different
names mainly after organ systems or
diseases that they work on and the
important thing is for the very
beginning and cats was and was viewed as
envisioned as and is operated as I we
operated as a as a collaborative
instrument and a convener if you will
but because of the position that we
occupy in the research echo system we
have more regular and and perhaps deeper
collaborations with organizations
outside d NIH then many of our
colleagues here and those are not only
with our conventional colleagues in
academia but also with disease advocacy
groups nonprofits of a government
agencies like the FDA in the EPA Pharma
biotech bc etc so now that we hopefully
understand the purpose of n cats that is
to put translation on a solid scientific
and operational footing and there
thereby get more treatments two more
patients more quickly what are the
problems that we work on and and this is
a partial list of the problems that we
work on you once you've noticed a couple
things about this one is that there
variously well known as being the causes
of either drug development or
intervention development a failure or
implementation failure at one level or
another or implementation and efficiency
and the second thing is that there are
no disease names in this list and this
is really the point everything mcats
works on or in what economists would
call the tragedy of the Commons that is
these are problems that are everybody's
problem in general but nobody's problem
in particular so nobody has ever worked
on really because it's minuites day job
these are our day job and so they are
things that we work on as our primary
mission but it's important that that
they're not just scientific problems are
operational problems too organizational
problems translation literally means
linguistically it actually means to
carry across and so translation by
definition means we are going from one
organization or one interest group if
you will to another whether that's from
biologists to chemists or chemist
informatics people or the preclinical
team to a clinical team or from clinical
to regulatory or regulatory to tip it to
physician groups or practice groups etc
there's always a handoff going on and so
whenever that happens it makes the
organizational challenges just that much
greater and we view these as areas of
scientific and organizational study as
well and these are just some of the
things that that we that we work on that
are limiting to translational efficiency
in that domain so in the scientific go
Mason of it we have sort of a rationale
and what are the problems that we work
on how do we actually get some good
things done it will probably not
surprise you that we've divided the
activities broadly into clinical
activities those are in in in human
subjects human participants in the
preclinical space that is going from
target validation into really first in
human studies and then work to
re-engineer the whole translational
process and I'm just going to show you
an example of each of these to just
illustrate the
nature the work that we do first on the
clinical side I'm going to spend the
least time on this because I think it
may be a less familiarity perhaps or
less relevance to this particular
audience it's very clear that even if we
had just as an example a drug for every
untreatable disease those six thousand
or so untreatable human diseases if we
had a drug for each one of those
diseases tomorrow we in no way have a
system in this country to be able to
test whether those drugs or any other
intervention is safe and effective and
there's a lot of reasons for this some
of it is because of our atomized
healthcare system but the important
thing is that that that the research
that needs to be done to translate a
novel intervention into human studies of
safety and efficacy and then in in two
populations is underdeveloped at best in
this country so there's a program called
the clinical translational science award
programs actually the NIH as biggest
single programs within mcats which has
within it 62 academic medical centers
that we call hubs many of the large
well-known academic health centers are
in this in this program we've saw an
unprecedented collection of key opinion
leaders and close to 100 million
patients cared for across this this
network and what we put in place more
recently is innovation centers that
address some of the real limiting
reagents to being able to get trials
done those include things like
multi-site central IRB human subjects
review contracting budgeting issues
which can hold up a trial getting
started for up to two years you can
imagine if you're a fundamental your
basic scientist imagine that you come up
with an idea but it takes two years to
get through all the approvals that you
can actually start your study scientist
ayan sunda mental
pre-clinical science would would advance
at a snail's pace and and this is really
the state of the art in science in the
sorry the clinical world onion though in
the the the green circle there's
illustrates our solution to one of the
other problems is that even when one can
get all the approvals upwards of half of
clinical studies which are started are
never completed because enough subjects
enough participants are not ever
recruited to actually answer the
experimental question that was asked in
the first place so remarkable a waste of
time spun wheels patients exposed to
potentially harmful or helpful
interventions without any information
coming out of them about whether they
were actually effective so again
tremendous waste of time and effort so
the whole idea is that via this network
over the next couple of years we will
put together a true national network for
translational medicine that will allow
us to do allow the research ecosystem
public sector private sector nonprofit
sector to be able to come to this
network and like the picture on the
lower left illustrates be able to treat
the CTSA program that network like a
like a supercomputer into which a
sponsor could could plug their USB and
get a stat rile started and kind of
just-in-time way so that's one of the
large innovative programs that mcats is
working on works on sort of a lower half
of that problem list that I showed you a
minute ago another clinical program that
we have and I'm going to move backwards
into the preclinical space another
clinical program is focused on rare
diseases and cats is interested in rare
diseases for for several reasons one
they are representative of disparate or
represent disproportionate unmet medical
need I mentioned that there are about
7,000 human diseases about 6,000 of
those are rare and all but about 250 of
them had no treatment
and so the question is how to accelerate
the rate of discovery development of
interventions which can treat these very
numerous rare diseases may interest you
to know that even though rare diseases
are individually rare by definition less
than 200,000 by the FDA definition given
the fact that there are about 6,000 of
these disorders the total number of
patients in the u.s. it has a rare
disease is somewhat north of 10 million
people so it's it's a significant issue
from a public health standpoint so this
rare disease clinical research Network
has two characteristics that I want to
illustrate for you one is the these
little ovals called PA GS this means
patient advocacy group this has been a
really critical innovation for this
network that is that you can't get
funded in this network without having a
patient group as a research partner that
has been invaluable at speeding up and
focusing the work of these these
programs and also bringing urgency to
the problems that are being addressed
the other is that you will notice that
if you look at the all the different
names and there's 22 different
consortium you'll notice that they don't
work on individual diseases and this is
on purpose these six thousand rare
diseases are of course not don't exist
in isolation they're all related to each
other in one way or another so all of
these programs were asked to organize
where diseases some corner of the rare
disease space by some organizing
biological principle either a
biochemical pathway for instance the
urea cycle disorders there on the right
or an organelle sale organelle like the
mitochondrial disorders consortium or
the lysosomal disease consortium or a
phenotype like a rare kidney zone stone
or vasculitis and this program has
because of those two things because of
the involvement of patient groups and
the involvement of the end the
organizational principle that we're
talking
about has really been remarkably
successful moving into the preclinical
or border in clinical preclinical space
some program that you may have heard
about is this new therapeutic useless
program the idea here is that about
eight out of ten drugs that are
developed in pharma or biotech that go
into people are never approved for own
reason or another so the idea was could
we partner with these pharmaceutical
companies and hook them up with academic
investigators that might have novel
ideas novel indications to which these
investigational drugs could be put and
then and then test them in a rapid
fashion and so it's a three-way
collaboration between pharma academic
researchers and mcats and these are the
the diseases that were that were the
projects that were funded about a year
and a half ago now you notice that they
are on mainly untreatable or poorly
treatable disorders and they have an
academic partner a former partner I just
want to illustrate one example here it's
a really interesting story that we think
may be an exon plar of things to come
this is a story about an astrazeneca
drug start kinase inhibitor that was
initially developed a course for cancer
didn't have great efficacy as a
standalone agent and cancer so was d
prioritized by astrazeneca an
investigator at yale about the same time
discovered that a sarkan ace family
member named Finn seemed to be involved
in emelan Alzheimer pathology and so
because of this program was able to go
from that discovery of Finn kinase and
Alzheimer's disease to testing the
hypothesis in animals and now in humans
about Finn inhibition
ameliorating Alzheimer pathology in
about a year and a half which is of
course significantly shorter than would
have taken to develop an NCD from
scratch moving further back now into the
division preclinical innovation which is
I think we're a lot of a lot of us in
the ACS operate on a daily basis we have
a collaborative program which has
investigators from around the world who
are stuck at these project entry points
at the top these arrows and they get
stuck at various places for various
reasons either expertise or or
experience or facilities and they come
in to our one of more of these programs
in the little boxes there and they
partner with n cats scientists to move
the project forward generate data or
reagents or drugs investigational drugs
to move these projects forward and I'll
just give you a couple of examples this
was one early effort in repurposing you
try and we're always trying to develop
general principles of course which are
going to improve the efficiency of the
translational pipeline it was very clear
it's very clear that of course virtually
all drugs have off target activities or
other activities from that which they
were originally intended some good some
bad and the good side that of course can
lead to repurposing but this is a it's
been a mainly serendipitous exercise so
we thought well gosh what we need to do
is put together a complete non redundant
list of every drug ever approved for
human use worldwide this had never been
done about six seven years ago we
started this this is now done there's a
website on our you can get to is up all
the data database is on our website you
can download the whole thing this is a
paper from a couple of years ago that
describes this and I'll just give you
one example of where were this has been
put to this is a story from a couple of
months ago this is a collaboration with
a liver researcher happens to be at the
National Institute for diabetes and
digestive and kidney disorders on
hepatitis C or all where I think of that
the
order and the new drugs would you come
out treating HCV very effective but of
course quite expensive this initiative
identified this old Allard
first-generation allergy drug core
cyclizine as being a very effective
inhibitor of hepatitis C replication and
cells and does not hit any of the
targets that have been identified before
that's clear we're still working on what
the target is but the important thing is
that this is already an approved drug
might be complementary to other other
therapies in his course would be quite
cheap given that it's been around for
about the last 50 years we do a lot of
patient driven science a lot of the uses
of the drug collection that I talked
about come not from scientists although
we work with hundreds of academic and
nonprofit and for-profit researchers but
they come from patients to this one on
shark only tooth this one on chordomas a
rare cancer in this one on muscle
disease called monotonic dystrophy
actually started because patients who
had these disorders oh came to end cats
and partnered with us to get these these
projects going and this has been a
remarkably effective counterpart to the
the more conventional academic or
scientifically initiated collaborations
I just want to give you one example of a
novel chemical probe development because
this is something we do a lot of as well
these we work a lot on the approximately
ninety percent of the genome which is
undrugged moving moving targets from the
under audible to the druggable category
we really don't work on things that
already is being worked on because most
of genome and disease space has not
worked on so this happens to be just an
example of several actually literally
hundred that I could I could show you
this happens to be on inhibitors of an
enzyme called trouble of oxygen asus in
a black box is on the record onic acid
pathway
was identified about 30 years ago but
because there were no selective chemical
inhibitors really wasn't understand good
what this enzyme did and so this part of
n Catskill Dean cgc collaborated with an
expert in my pocket so you see santa
cruz over the course of about two years
developed and as they did a
high-throughput screening of about
400,000 compounds did the chemical
informatics and about two years of med
chem leading to these enanta more
specific first and enter specific 12 hlo
inhibitors and using those probes and
then we were able to dissect what this
enzyme actually does in cells and then
in tissues turns out it's involved in
both diabetes and thrombosis that then
led to collaborations with peoples in
those fields and then a research
collaboration agreement with Santa Fe to
further characterize and develop those
inhibitors so so there's a great example
of a target that we started working on
simply because it was undrugged and were
able to dissect novel biology and
potentially new therapeutics as a result
of it and lots of papers of course this
one I happy p from j med can let's say
however you were at that point where you
develop a draw a probe or on a
repurposed drug but it's not for a
common disease like from boces but for a
rare disease the they're rarely are
going to be companies that are
interested in those probes so this is a
program to go from a probe to first in
human development again and it's this
collaborative way that in cats does
everything here's just one example of
that this is a compound up there in the
upper right corner was initially
identified Virginia Commonwealth
University about 20 years ago by a
researcher who's now now retired it was
not developed by that researcher was the
IP was acquired by this little company
in Boston called SRX it's a kind of a
scary compound from a chemical
standpoint has also a potential very
interesting but potentially problematic
mechanism which is shown in the graph
below which is that it binds to sickle
hemoglobin
and shifts the oxygen dissociation curve
to the left what that means is that it
reverses the fundamental molecular
defect of sickle-cell disease which is
very attractive but the question was
would this compound bind to many other
proteins in the proteome and cause
toxicity didn't but that was the concern
and so this this compound and this
company was dead in the water not able
to move it forward even though
supercells are very important and from a
mechanism standpoint is untreatable
disorder so trend that it's part of this
there p.s were very neglected diseases
programming part of mcats partnered with
this company did all the tox c and c
regulatory work out into humans in about
a year from signing the agreement got
through the phase 1 and phase 2 trials
and as a result of this the whole
program was adapted was acquired by
baxter for completion of clinical
development what's it been to de-risk
initially in humans I'm going to skip
through this tox part quickly I just
want to let you know what's going on
here there's a large tots collaboration
that we're doing with the national
toxicology program the EPA and the FDA
to call tox 21 it's a massive systems
biology experiment testing about 10,000
chemicals drugs and environmental
chemicals for the pathways that they
interact with as a way to understand the
toxicity of chemicals and eventually to
develop predictive models for biological
response in humans important things for
all of you on the phone call is that
this is a community resource project and
all of the data from this program are
put in public databases either actor
from EPA or pubchem from from the NIH
there have been about a hundred million
data points from this program that is a
chemical that is at a concentration
against a against a biological assay
that has been made public in the last
three or four years from this program so
if you're a modeler please go to it and
tell if you can come up with novel
predictive models based on all these
data I just want to finish with this
which is gives you a sense of where in
Katz's going this is one of a one of the
reagent hearing programs the another
approach to the toxicity problem that's
complementary to the tox 21 program is
is this program to develop
three-dimensional organoids of all human
tissues that are targets of xenobiotic
toxicity it's a program which is
developing microfluidic microphone
amaanka political platform models of all
of these ten organs that you can see
there in front of you and they have to
be anatomically and functionally correct
and work for at least a month give you a
sense of how this works they all start
with a exerciser matrix of some sort the
cells are added there the primary cells
or IPS cell derived cells they have to
have a given structure that's either
given to them where they self assemble
depending on the organ of course they
have ever have the right spatial and
temporal patterning sometimes they have
to be perfused because remember these
are alive for a month they had to be in
the right bioreactor to keep them alive
during that time they sometimes have to
be innovated in order to give either the
efficacy or toxicity readout that we're
interested in they frequently have to
have a toast for a host response
especially if we're interested in
toxicity that have a particular
functional lead out that's
non-destructive and we have to have a
computational design that allows us to
gather the information and all of this
has to be done in a modular way so that
we can mix and match these various
organs and a just give you one quick
example this happens to be the heart in
this example of cardiomyocytes you're
probably well aware differentiate from
IPS cells quite readily however they
don't mature into mature cardiomyocytes
they remain rather immature and
therefore their responses to drugs are
not terribly
consistent with what happens in bebo
however if one takes these a sheet of
these cells out and exposes them to the
same stretch and relaxation that a
normal heart would undergo actually this
is how these these cells actually
differentiate form sarcomeres form Z
bands and actually begin to respond to
drugs in a more physiologically relevant
way so where we're going here is in the
end of the next five-year funding period
and we're going to do this already to
have all 10 tissues on a single
[ __ ] microphone with a platform
where one could for example infuse a
drug meant there and the little blue
circles there and the bottom right of
the figure in artificial blood would go
to an hour official gut and get absorbed
or not go to an artificial liver and get
metabolized or not and then go to an
artificial kidney tubular for instance
and cause tubular necrosis or not just
as an example one can put in or take out
drug at any phase of this to do analysis
for instance do analyte analysis etc and
of course one doesn't need all ten
together one can put in a heart and lung
together or liver and kidney together
whatever one would want and of course
all these readouts have to be correlated
with the invivo readouts which is what's
going on now there's a lot of work going
on to test the whether these systems
respond to both approved drugs and drugs
that have failed in ways that mirror the
clinical response in humans the other
interesting thing to sort of leave with
you is that because each of these chips
is made from either primary cells are
more commonly IPS induced pluripotent
stem cells these chips can be made from
individuals that is each of us on this
webinar could have their own chip made
and therefore one can begin to look at
interindividual variability in ways that
are simply impossible
comic so I think that is it I'm going to
try to go I went backwards unfortunately
so I'm going to go forward here I think
that yeah so that is it I'm glad to take
any questions if we have time if there's
yeah of course if you're looking for
more information we have a good website
we just redesigned a lot of information
contacts all the people that you might
want to meet there how to work with us
at Sarah and at that point I guess I'll
hand it back over to Mitch and we can
take any questions hi Chris thank you
that was a great and very interesting
talk we have a the first question is
from roberta brinton from University of
Southern California they were wondering
what is in cats doing to help change
academic publishing and funding
incentives to promote collaborative
transparent and reproducible research
day meeting were having here today about
that very issue a lot of this is going
on through the CTSA program which is
resident at most big academic medical
centers and yes the goal is both
initially to have these centers
appreciate some some fields some
disciplines which are non-traditional
among which are medicinal chemistry for
instance at many places entrepreneurship
regulatory science these kinds of things
but also to to help them realize that
translation as we like to say around
here is an obligatory team sport and in
a world that is still
for the most part in many places at
least run on whether an investigator has
a first or last author publication in a
one-word journal and those are required
for promotion and tenure really a
translation is going to be limited and
it's at and its efficacy in those in
those environments because the middle
authors those really critical people in
any team are not going to get academic
credit so so we're working very hard on
that to our long-term goal is to have a
robust academic discipline of
translational medicine which has
probably different different a different
culture different promotion and tenure
requirements because the the science
that it does is different it's not
better worse than fundamental science
it's just different okay our next
question is from foster Devon from the
National chemical laboratory and they're
wondering in case of repurposing of a
drug how can one deal with IP or
intellectual property issues I mean soon
as you use a quick it's a question that
I get asked a lot I would say there is a
couple different answers first of all
the collection that we have because it
represents the historical accretion of
every drug ever made it's made up mainly
of generic drugs about ninety percent of
the collection is off patent for for
temporal reasons comas that are on
patent of course we need to and actually
want to go to the to the originator
company the innovator company and work
with them to develop the compound and
that's what the new therapeutic uses
program does the the Siq adnate program
that i mentioned that's the SAR kinase
family inhibitor that's being repurposed
for Alzheimer's disease that is a very
close partnership with astrazeneca and
yeah
working together on the on the more
common problem we have actually is that
there is no intellectual property on
these on these generic drugs and that
makes it very difficult to fund the
clinical trials the definitive clinical
trials which are required for
registration that is a problem that we
are still working on and I don't don't
hesitate don't pretend to have an answer
to that there's no way to recoup the
investment required the at least 10
closer to 100 million dollars sometimes
to do a registration trial depending on
the drawing the disease and the drug
there's no way one can do that in a
return on investment environment it's a
two large amount of money for in a and I
H Institute or Center to do really for
the most part and it's too much money
for a non-profit to so so we've been
talking with many different partners
about different kinds of incentives
different kinds of work that we might do
to look at evidentiary standards rather
than regulatory approval per se to get
these into medical use so we receive two
very similar questions I'm going to do
my best to kind of them digest it it's
both are from all of our gunman from
University of Florida and it's from
Sankey from a cat thumb University and
they were wondering what type of
training or education would be suitable
for future researchers that want to be
more involved in translational research
great question and thank you thank you
for the question it's something near and
dear to my heart and everybody here
first I should say that it will
not surprise you to learn that I think
this is a wonderful time for
investigators who especially younger
investigators who are interested in
getting into this space that and I know
probably all of you are tired of hearing
this but it really is true that the
opportunities available now compared to
when I was in training 30 years ago are
just are just mind-blowing Lee larger
and I tried to illustrate that at the
beginning I would say a couple things
first it's important to have some
expertise that's deep expertise that you
can bring to the team whether that's in
biologic biology or chemistry or
oncology or informatics or clinical
studies or whatever public health would
have you but but you also need to learn
unlike in least the way I was trained
you need to learn enough about all of
those other areas that I just went
through to understand what your
teammates are going to do and so the way
I sometimes explain this is it's it's
like learning how to how to play on an
American football team that is you know
you could be the best quarterback in the
world but you really have to understand
what the center does what the offensive
lineman does what the what the wide
receivers do or else you're never going
to score any touchdowns and so and
that's a bit different from how
scientific training has typically been
done which is in a very purposely narrow
narrow way in a narrow field that is
still appropriate for folks who are
going to be looking at fundamental
mechanisms where that training is is is
often fine but for translational lists
it's simply it simply isn't doesn't work
the other thing that you should think
about is is is a way to either learn
about or even better spend some time in
places outside of academia that are part
of the the translational ecosystem and
by that I'm including Pharma biotech
venture capital on one side regulatory
agencies like the FDA on other patient
groups who are increasingly both driving
and funding some of this work in very
sophisticated ways it's really important
to understand their points of view in
order to be both psychologically and
culturally multilingual as well as
scientifically understand where they're
coming from so it's a guess the way I
another analogy that might help is you
need to think about yourself the way
maybe you did when you were in college
that is that you had a major which you
knew a lot about but you also had
perhaps distribution requirements and he
didn't know a little bit about
everything about math and science and
humanities and art and all these other
things we say you had a broad background
on all fields but then you had a major
that you knew specifically something
about that allows you to be a good team
player so that's all the time we have
many things Chris for your presentation
and thanks to all of you for tuning in
there'll be more great talks beginning
at the top of the hour and throughout
the day you can find a full program on
the agenda page located at the upper
right-hand side of your screen in the
meantime please stop by the virtual
exhibit and the lounge to check out our
sponsors and exhibitors or network with
other attendees join the conversation on
twitter with hashtag cen 715